hey what's up my name's samuel leeds i'm
a property investor and when i started
out investing in property there was
literally no one around that i could ask
a straight property question to that
would give me a straight answer so in
this video i decided to answer all of
your questions that you have around
property and around property investment
all you got to do is just comment below
and i'll do my best to answer your
questions on the next q a video and the
thing is if someone has a question and i
answer it
you listening in is actually going to be
really helpful as well because there's
only so many problems and questions that
they can possibly be so if i'm answering
other people's questions and problems
you're going to be able to take notes
and that's going to help you in your
journey to becoming successful in
property as well so take good notes ask
good questions and let's see what we got
so edgar costa says
if you view a property that has got land
at the side without planning permission
it's big enough to build at least
another two houses on the land however
the existing property has structural
issues that are not historical causing
the refurb cost to rise what would you
do with this deal
that sounds like a perfect deal i love
the fact that it hasn't got planning
permission the house the worst the
problems the house has the better the
profit in this deal so if there's
structural problems brilliant news
because
most people are going to be looking at
this house and thinking oh it's got
structural problems it's i'm not
bothered about the house i'm thinking
about the land
you could buy the house
literally don't even fix the structural
issues do nothing with it and then you
could sell the house at auction
for about what you paid for it but then
just sell it without the land and then
bang you've got some free land
so
no issues whatsoever maybe get a
structural engineer to have a look at it
because it might be that the
the actual house doesn't need as much
money as you thought spending on it as
possible but i'm very interested in this
deal i hope to see you man i hope to see
you soon hope so you do well
uh mr s says i've seen that most of the
birming most of birmingham's article 4
which makes finding a rent to rent
harder
i also tried contacting current hmo
listings on spare room and open rent
like you've shown us at the millionaire
intensive but no luck
are there other ways to find good hmo
deals and do you think there are enough
deals to go around people usually talk
about not having the funds but for the
deals i seem to that to be the
struggling part actually finding deals
firstly you correct that it is harder to
find the deals than to find the money
people say oh i haven't got any money i
can't get into property it's like hold
on even if i gave you a million pounds
tomorrow you wouldn't know what to do
with it let's get real so you're right
the biggest problem is not lack of money
it's lack of good deals that need money
so that being said by the way that's
some of you might be thinking about
having um
i'm having a go at you i'm saying you're
rubbish that's actually a good thing
because that means that you don't need
to find the money before you start
searching for the deal right now today
you could go start searching for the
deal and if the good deal comes the
money will follow it always does
so
listen in birmingham you can literally
go onto
the council website and see a list of
every single hmo in the entirety of
birmingham
so i think your problem is you've
probably not spoken to enough people
this is a numbers game and a skills game
you've got to speak to see more people
see more people see more people but also
don't say don't contact landlords and
agents and say do you do corporate let's
you got to go in with a story you've got
to go in and say hi this is my situation
this is what i'm looking for this is who
i am build rapport let them like you
people do business with people that they
know like and trust build rapport
tell me your story
and then ask them for the business
okay so good luck
all right mark coos
how do the real estate agents make their
commission if you do a rent to rent or a
lease option with the landlord why would
they be willing to put you in contact
with the landlord if they don't make a
commission
so
a lease option agreement
usually if they're listed with an agent
the agent can't sell the property
because the property is overpriced the
property's been on the market for five
years
and they can't sell it because it's
overpriced but the mortgage is so high
that they can't drop the price so the
agent's done with the property anyway
the agent's just like
whatever so you come on in
you don't even do it through the agent
you're gonna you're gonna contact the
landlord direct you can buy their title
deeds
on land registry for three pounds
contact them
direct and say hey i can see you
struggling to sell your house it's been
on the market for five years
i can see this in negative equity
you know what i'd like to make you an
offer which is like a rent to buy type
arrangement can we have a conversation
and then if they end up giving you the
deal a lease option agreement get the
deal then go back to the agent say to
the agent hey um i actually just secured
a lease option agreement on this
property i feel kind of bad um look can
i can i pay you your fee or something
and they'll be like well there's a lot
more where that came from you know
so i mean we're renting to rent they
will get paid they'll just get a small
percentage each month so it depends on
the deal but i hope that kind of answers
your question i hope to see you at the
crash course soon my friend awesome
will alexander says can you package and
sell deals as a teenager eg age 17 or
18.
um
yes
you can if you're 18 years old you're an
adult
you can do whatever you want
in england
uk you can get married
you can
travel the world you can set up a
business you can build an empire
do what you want
no different from a 28 year old
if you're 17 you are technically in the
uk you're a minor
so you can't set up a business bank as a
17 year old because you're a minor if
you're 16 17 you can't set up a business
bank
however you do have
a
national insurance number
you you should usually get a national
insurance number actually age 15 just
before you turn 16.
my videographer just told me that
information so thank you cara so when
you turn 16 if you've got a national
insurance number you can trade as a sole
trader and you can get paid so if you
want to help people you want to be a
deal sourcer
what i used to do when i was like 16
well 17 was i used to i worked as a sole
trader i used to find people tenants for
their rooms and just charge i was
getting paid for my time it's going to
be a deal source you can just say hey
can i go out on viewings and help find
you properties and you'll just get paid
by investors and landlords for your time
and then when you turn 18 and set up a
business you've now got a bit of money
behind you a bit of experience so yes
you can it's the is the simple answer
all right js says how do you systemize a
deal sourcing business and still earn a
grand fee from deals um you systemize it
by firstly you've got to focus on
actually making money packaging and
selling deals once you're packaging and
selling deals and you're making money
that's what you're just going to stop
bringing in staff
hiring
people to run the business for you
all right last question and then hey i
want to answer your questions so don't
forget comment below your questions
comment and comment and comment them and
i'll be answering them on the next q a
video so
abdelkansa says
what do you think about drop shipping
listen drop shipping as i don't know
lots about drop shipping i don't know
much about anything all i really know
about is how to make money in property i
know if we think about property or
different strategies drop shipping as
far as i'm aware drop shipping is when
people buy things on amazon or ebay and
then sell them for slightly more
expensive and make a profit
i think it's cool man if my kids want to
do that that's fine but
when you become
you know
a bit older
i would imagine that it would make more
sense to do that with instead of
packaging and selling pencils and
small little things and pokemon cards i
would imagine that it would make more
sense to do that with property right
find property deals negotiate to buy
them cheap and then wholesale them on
your profit if your profit margins are
10 20
if you're doing that with
one million pound houses
you're gonna make far more money every
time you do a deal than you are if
you're doing it so
uh i don't really know much about drop
shipping but hey i'm gonna encourage
anybody that's wanting to be an
entrepreneur so
hope that helps speak to you soon guys
look forward to reading your comments
below god bless peace out
[Music]